in the last month since SNL Jason has
been traveling a lot and sending us
videos so let's see a you I'm in my
favorite place in London I'm coming to
you soon I can't wait to see
you K
Clarkson mama I'm going see you soon
right now I'm in
shanga damn it look good I'm in Beijing
right now but uh it's going to take me a
while I got a little bit of a walk so
I'll see you soon
baby
it's awesome I think we're so blessed
because in our in the entertainment
industry you get to travel to so many
cool places what's like one of your
favorite places you been I mean that's
pretty amazing to be on the Great Wall I
know I've always wanted to do it it was
yeah I've had a couple opportunities but
just uh that was it it that was
phenomenal and then I've never been on
top of that building looking at Shanghai
like that was it was I mean CH the China
was pretty epic yeah it's been two weeks
we've been traveling Brazil China like I
have no idea where I'm at right now you
have no idea look I can k
you you know
why you're my you're the Finish Line I'm
you're the Finish Line
oh no I know that promo schedule and
you're cuz I can tell by your voice when
you first spoke I was like oh brother is
tired yeah yeah you've got that deep
thing that happens when you wake up
tired I don't even know what it is yeah
you know then it gets fun it gets silly
you just start laughing and crying
hysterically at the same time well we'll
enjoy this moment so you travel you
travel with a guitar and a speaker do
you like busk everywhere what do you
what do you do
there well I'm kind of like you okay
then you must be nuts yeah yeah there's
a lot going on so I feel like it just it
it helps me sit still and be quiet so
like it's nice to have something that
just calms me so music helps and then
obviously playing guitar just helps my
creativity so I I I can just no I'm have
to do that yeah so it guitar just helps
me yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home